tens of millions of americans will drive
or fly for the thanksgiving holiday
despite the pandemic
cbs news has learned the tsa expects to
screen more than six million people
as chris van cleave reports that's
leading to concerns about an even bigger
surge in the virus nationwide
a socially distanced thanksgiving came
early for laura douglas's family
celebrating outside in october there
were fewer guests visiting family were
spaced apart at separate tables
and masks were worn it allowed the
family to be together
but not too close together my mother is
a cancer patient
so she's at high risk and we knew that
there would be no way to spend time with
my parents
if we didn't figure out something that
was very very different
this year will be different aaa's newly
released thanksgiving travel forecast
expects
up to 50 million will travel down at
least 10 percent from last year
95 percent will drive as people opt for
last minute trips and stay closer to
home
aaa believes those flying will drop
nearly 48 percent
but airlines are gearing up for their
busiest stretch since the start of the
pandemic
this travel holiday comes as the cdc
warns even
small household gatherings are an
important contributor to the rise in
covet 19 cases
former cdc director dr thomas frieden
unfortunately
because so many people may get together
during thanksgiving
at a time when coveted rates are so high
we might see explosive spread through
the month of december
and the december holidays would become a
very unmerry
christmas the cdc is encouraging people
who do gather for thanksgiving to
keep it small your immediate household
or a small group
of close contacts ideally who live in
the same area you do
wear a mask when you're not eating try
to be outdoors if you're indoors open as
many windows as you can to increase
ventilation
and stay out of cramped spaces which for
many may mean staying out of the kitchen
chris van cleave cbs news reagan
national airport
virginia